so deal was rescued from the rubble of
her home in Northwest Syria which too
was hit hard by Monday's earthquake in
southern turkey as this six-year-old
girl recounts the horror of her
experience she still doesn't know how
much she has lost
the building swayed from one side to
another and there was destruction
everywhere I heard my mother calling my
father's name I then lost Consciousness
and woke up at the hospital I didn't
lose anyone in the Quake but I haven't
seen anyone yet
today her father and three of her
siblings died
the deal doesn't know yet we also didn't
tell her mother because we're concerned
about their health
stories of survival and deaths are heard
over and over again
the biggest natural disaster to hit the
region in decades is the latest crisis
for the people of Syria who have
experienced years of war displacement
and hunger Aid agencies warn the worst
is yet to come there's a lack of
everything and uh and and and of course
it's called the winter is going on so
people need to be kept warm
um we've set up a small clinics just to
look after people's injuries
Syria's Health Care system was already
struggling due to the war the World
Health Organization says at least 20
Health Facilities across the
opposition-controlled Northwest
including four hospitals had sustained
damage and while Emergency Medical
Services have been overwhelmed with
trauma patients Essential Health
Services have been severely disrupted
as you can see part of the hospital was
damaged we lacked doctors and medical
supplies to deal with such a big
emergency the needs are enormous and we
don't have enough resources
Aid has started to flow in but the needs
are on an unprecedented scale the United
Nations is coordinating its Disaster
Response from government-controlled
areas where it says it is working to
gain approvals from Damascus for faster
and more regular access to the northwest
but people there say it is too late
countless lives they say have been lost
because their appeals for help were
ignored by the International Community